you're listening to the dollop this is a
biweekly American history podcast each
week I read a story from American
history to my friend Gareth Reynolds who
has no idea what the topic is going to
be about oh you have notes it was what
almost luxury and devoid of humanity
what are you talkin to yourself on this
before just cuz you did one normal last
episode doesn't mean that now you know
how to do it I'm like an angel but
nobody agrees with that I mean I'm an
Angelica podcast nobody agrees with that
except the angel podcaster union of
America yeah really I'd love to see some
paperwork I'm are very behind me love
the season may for a business card just
one email some proof of its existence
would be nice not Garry Gareth Dave okay
someone or something is tickling and
this is not gonna tickle a quite a bunch
of religious virgins go to mingle and do
what ray
Grethe sorry what what the [ __ ] did you
just say Grethe Gareth okay sorry it's
not that is my name
I said it no you didn't Griffin Yadav we
we have a gig come up in Chicago that
tickets are still available for the
Lincoln Hall on April 18th 9 p.m. show
New York shows sold out on 17th you you
snooze you lost you have regrets don't
think that's the expression next time
you will handle this situation better
okay
tickets are on sale for the Los Angeles
podcast festival which is September 23
24 25 and Beverly Hills go to LA upon
fest com2 get your tickets earlier you
get them the cheaper they'll be how
about them apples also we got to mention
that this podcast is sponsored by our
subscribers at patreon subscribers at
patreon you are the wind beneath our
podcasting wings without you we're
unable to soar through the skies of
auditory entertainment and for us to
flourish in our natural habitat we need
the digital feedings that you display on
the patreon as often as you do while
Dave and I are in the skies and in the
nest and dave is eating food and
regurgitating into my mouth and
vice-versa that food is sponsored by you
guys that is the food you guys have
helped us with and gosh we can't thank
you enough as we like to say
I hope you enjoyed the dollar podcast
Dave Pedro plugs out of the way about
know I did that I know I can see his
people you watch I bet they're amazing
their subscriptions you you watch I bet
the numbers go up after this one you
March 14 93g
what it's a while ago yeah guess what
happened on that at that time it's not a
hard one to figure out 1493 Columbus
there it is well that's the ocean lumbus
returned to Europe from America well in
America he managed to drop off some
diseases which included smallpox which
began ravaging and Native Americans yep
but he also discovered land that people
already had found thank you all evidence
points to Columbus bring you back
something with him to Europe syphilis oh
man the first sign of so now that would
be that it is from from [ __ ] right
that's what he got it from yeah they
[ __ ] yeah they did a lot is that the
only but that is what he that's how you
the only way you could tract it you're
strike um you know back then they're not
sure like it may nothing like back then
if you like touch the wall wrong you
could get yeah back then it was a little
more contagious a little more maybe like
leprosy but it has changed over time and
be leprosy the disease that turns people
into leprechauns yes right
that's how leprechauns exist okay so he
comes back hot-to-trot and syphilitic
and syphilitic or someone in his crew
does okay the first sign of syphilis
hitting Europe was in August 14 94 King
Charles the eighth of France led 50,000
soldiers into northern Italy they were
mostly mercenaries some of whom were
from Spain that's where Columbus landed
right work with me I'm working and along
with them traveled cooks medical workers
and prostitutes well I mean obviously
you you need to stay healthy you need to
eat and you got to get your dick wet
right if you're gonna have three or you
might as well have sex by the way if
you're a prostitute like but that work
is already shitty but this sort of line
of work is probably particularly [ __ ]
can't be great it's not it can't be
great yeah like at least you could clock
out right in the old days but not on
this not on this trip no you're on the
clock you're early you're like a doctor
getting paged while occupying Naples the
mercenaries had some fun and partied
very soon became apparent they had a new
disease it was brutal and fast-moving it
started with
officers on the genitals yeah that is
right off the bat a terrible start and
you just winked at me I think so yeah
not okay but a month or so later came
the terrible pain ten weeks later a rash
that looked like chickenpox the ulcers
all over or just around the date all
over all over then the ulcers in the
mouth the hair would start to fall out
in patches a year or so later came the
wasting away
gross abscesses all over and bone
swelling sores would devour the eyes and
noses oh my god parts of people's faces
would just fall off Oh God okay simple
this was a lot better lot worse it's
like you're mr. Potato Head
it was a lot worse back then oh [ __ ]
quote it caused flesh to fall from
people's faces I'd be what and led to
death within a few months for some there
was the complete destruction of the lips
others of the nose and all of their
genitals can you imagine like trying to
play it off like you didn't have it if
you just wanted to get laid but I have
I'm gonna have lips I know I had them
taken off because I didn't like where I
was keeping drink what about the fact
that part of your nose just fell off um
I had to that's okay I will admit a
widdle abnormal uh-huh but it happens to
the best of us get your close-up but it
had some wine I believe let's have some
wine you you didn't hear the last thing
I said my [ __ ] is so bad for some people
their genitals came off so fell off that
is there were different says the
complete destruction of all their
genitals this is all how does that even
work with a woman it's already a woman a
man put your stuff lady stuff could fall
off there's stuff there they could my
vagina's dropped not the whole thing the
whole thing the prayers outer parts yeah
I guess
not something and what was like what
were the options I mean there was no
real options as far as like preventative
oh there's no measures like you just raw
dog yeah you're rotting there was I wish
I could find it I couldn't find it
because I had seen that a long time ago
when I was doing research about this but
there was a town in Italy where the
whole town of been hit by it and they
described the town and it was just
people walking around with just their
faces rotting off the final phase was
severe debility madness and death by the
end of 14.95 syphilis had spread through
france switzerland and germany it was in
England and Scotland in 1497 by 1500 it
was in Scandinavian countries Hungary
Greece Poland and Russia soon it was off
to Africa China and Japan since it
wasn't called syphilis yet it had a
bunch of different names the French
called it the Spanish disease
interesting the Italians called it the
French disease okay
the Germans called it the French evil
okay the Russians called it the Polish
disease interesting the Polish and the
Persians called it the Turkish disease
so who the Turkish call that the
Christian disease alrighty India it was
called the Portuguese disease alright in
Japan it was called the Chinese pox Oh
interesting Japan always changing it up
on us nothing new there so the blame
game is what it should have been called
a little bit Wow the treatment of
syphilis may have been worse than actual
syphilis there was a holy holy wood
which was thought to have come from the
tree Jesus's cross was made from and so
they would just put that around so I'd
be like just what is from the tree that
Jesus that they made Jesus cross from so
clearly it's gonna help you because
Jesus was healed by the I thought holy
wood was restored all the actors moved
no that's Holly oh right
but wait she would just take boy you see
crucifix wouldn't be like here put this
in your absent genital box not even
number one that's a weird thing to say
to someone but number two it's not even
it's it's just tree wood tree wood that
is associated with Jesus
I'm from the tree that the cross was
born but I'm gonna go ahead and just say
that the tree that the they made the
cross that it was cut down yeah it's not
like they took out beams oh yeah I mean
what are they it's not a home depot this
is a [ __ ] tree so there's some
problems with holy wood okay but
regardless you know yet mainly the
lawyers but regardless they're there
what they do is they just take they just
take this wood and what just like be
like sniffing sniff the wood yeah you
know put it around grab the wood on your
horrible source your balls
pick your pick your ball stores with
this wood Jesus liked it look it didn't
work
Oh shot so if the Hollywood didn't work
then they tried mercury always always a
fun second option one would be rubbed
with mercury three times a day and left
next to a hot fire to sweat this went on
for up to a month
now unfortunately Mercury's not actually
good for you
mercury is terrible for you it's really
the horrible poison it's a poison so one
would suffer from perfuse sweating
kidney failure severe mouth ulcers and
loss of teeth
a Russian of the bones and mental
instability remember it makes you crazy
yeah a lot of people being treated with
mercury treatment died from mercury
treatment so really what mercury was was
like do you want to have a crazy last
month they weren't like you'll be fine
they're like you'll die by a fire what
do you want how shitty do you feel how
shitty do you feel shitty enough yeah
I'm a red poison on you lay by this fire
I'm gonna roll you by the fire you'll
miss the days when you just want to head
to genitals remember when your Janus
channels were just falling that was your
biggest problem not anymore fire boy in
America syphilis was present at
Jamestown Virginia there was an outbreak
in Boston in 1646 oh man
[ __ ] balls are killing me ah thought
I [ __ ] can't even feel my deck my
[ __ ] lips dropped off [ __ ]
a man brought it into town after working
on a ship and gave it to his wife pretty
soon here you are honey something from
the road
pretty soon 15 people in the town had it
well okay seeing mavar I got fidelity
math is easy there yeah there's an issue
there someone [ __ ] someone [ __ ] a
lot of people's the wife is other people
are [ __ ] a lot of people everybody's
[ __ ] in the early 1700s author and
pusher of the smallpox vaccine Cotton
Mather explained about how many
prostitutes in town were infected with
syphilis all deaths were recorded being
due to consumption being what he made
well consumptions TB so they wouldn't
say people died of syphilis
oh they right in 1724 the governor of
Louisiana said there were so many quote
useless women infected with syphilis who
were ruining the sailors yeah you know
it really if you've got to find a
scapegoat or escape genital I mean look
no further than the ladies yeah there's
no way the sailors are paying it's not
the sailors no not the sailors it's not
the sailors so those are the best the
women are the only ones spreading it
they're giving it to the men so the
governor of Louisiana his solution was
to send all the syphilitic useless women
into the middle of a country where they
could infect the Native Americans what
what is this plan his place their
weapons now his plan is to just send
like Fembots into the middle of the
[ __ ] country to [ __ ] Native Americans
the small to syphilis deaths yeah I
don't hate it I mean it's not a bad idea
the only drawback is is that's where
syphilis came from right you're probably
already yeah and they're mean yeah talk
to chief no mouth he was evil see if
your plan works for us venereal diseases
got much worse when the Revolutionary
War began after the Battle of New York
General George Washington complained
about how many of his men were unfit for
duty because of syphilis it's so funny
to think that the found like one of the
founding fathers had to be like these
men have [ __ ] too much I mean that and
we were not taught that
no that's not turns out we weren't
taught a lot about George Washington the
Continental Congress in 1778 voted to
fine every soldier for dollars who was
hospitalized with venereal disease great
plan that's how you that's that'll fix
up now find him when Lewis and Clark
made their famous journey across America
in 1804
they brought three different mercury
treatments for syphilis liquid pills and
an ointment the men on the expedition
had a lot of sex with Native American
women but they already had syphilis and
known as sure who gave it to whom how
great would it be if somebody could
invent some sort of thing to put around
your dick like a like a lady bingo oh
wait that's actually you're right we're
already doing that fits right around it
- yeah I don't know when condoms came
along but you know the first condoms
were made of sheeps blood right I don't
think that per that doesn't prevent
anything no that's very permeable still
fun to [ __ ] you gotta have latex yeah in
latex isn't very far off some I mean
there's there's could be something what
I mean burlap sack like yeah I'm sort of
I'm sort of picturing you know maybe one
of those things you drink made out of
yeah this lamb things things you drink
meat out what is it called the thing
well I've never heard of drinking meat
out of things the thing you have wrapped
around your neck it's like a [ __ ]
like hairy canteen you're making less
sense I'm not talking about testicles a
hairy canteen that you drink meat out of
Mead Mead not means meat need not meat
meat no not talked about like some
random meat drink you know a gravy bag
you know for those long johns you get
real thirsty of the hot hot Sun you want
to treat yourself to some hot gravy bag
cork where's my gravy bag bring me the
gravy I've got quite a thirst to quench
I'll tell you sometimes I think that
gravy is making me thirsty
I am parched sorry to think it was a bad
idea to fill these up with gravy instead
of water anyone with me
gentlemen I'm Jake and me actually all
are - okay so we were we were solving
the contraceptive problems of the 49ers
in 1812 the US War Office declared that
no one would get their pay while being
treated for syphilis
I you know it really is very like
somewhat like it's just like similar
tactics always it's just like find them
it's like no yeah help them get help
them Wars always seemed to increase the
number of prostitutes and the spread of
syphilis by 1850 there were 6,000
prostitutes in New York City over 500
brothels in Chicago the civil war
increased prostitute numbers in all
major cities sex workers often did
laundry work and hung around near
military posts hot yeah right yeah I'm
watching these clothes you wanna [ __ ] oh
my god more than anything I'm Robin I'm
robbing these quit rubbing those sheets
and start rubbing this guy okay all
righty
when the Union Army took over Nashville
and Memphis in 1864 they legalized
prostitution the sex workers were
licensed and given weekly medical exams
if they were infected they were sent to
a special hospital for treatment each
prostitute was taxed 50 cents a week to
cover the costs what a terrible idea
I know foolish way to handle that so the
only time we ever did everything right
was in 1864 in Memphis and Nashville yep
just like we all thought of course
mercury continued to be used as the main
treatment oh well sorry girls after the
war was over they got rid of that but
people believe syphilis was spread not
just from sexual contact they thought
you'd get it from kissing public
drinking fountains towels linens and
many other ways
okay like AIDS in the eighties right
yeah in July of 1870 didn't have a Nancy
Reagan therefore that they did not she
was so great as well very helpful really
helpful in July of 1870 the st. Louis
City Council enacted what was called the
quote social clause social evil
ordinance whoa what it is it is funny
because it's like now we put like such a
shine on these laws that are meant to
[ __ ] people the No Child Left Behind Act
is like buttah Beckman it would just be
like what's marketing anyway let's just
call it everyone's evil you're all bad
okay the ordinance appointed six doctors
to license and inspect registered
prostitutes it was if it was discovered
a sex worker had syphilis she would be
sent to what was called the social evil
hospital why would you where are you
headed
social evil yeah I don't know I got this
if Jenna doesn't really [ __ ] up I
guess what that means I'm evil my ear
dropped off so I have to go get punished
the woman would remain there until she
was certified as cured the social evil
ordinance was but you when you were
getting cured you were getting cured
through like what methods through
through mercury yes so just sometimes it
makes just your fight you're walking
that fine line between poisoning
yourself and but it would go what like
the symptoms would go away after a while
and then you have it but you're not
showing anything for a while and then
they you know they come back and they're
worse right then your shits falling off
you know so so there's a period where
you look okay okay right the social evil
ordinance was in place for four years
until the state legislature got rid of
it though doctors continue to argue this
was the best way to stop the spread of
syphilis in 1880 the American Public
Health Association appointed a committee
on the Prevention of venereal disease
what a great committee yeah there's
nothing better than when you got to get
like older serious people together for
something about like a penis order the
first committee on the Prevention of the
nail disease yes I actually have I would
love to be able to tweak but I think you
actually probably have a lot to say
because I yeah very good yeah thank you
yeah right anyway I'm whatever where's
your nose right here baby's got your
nose not falling for that again
I okay okay I'll sit down cuz obviously
okay thank you don't leave any parts of
you and you get up I was think I was
told this is something different than
what it is okay well this is the
Committee on prevention of venereal
disease the main way we do that is by
mocking and making fun of me okay well
great tactics the committee issued a
report saying that syphilis could quote
lurk and even affect pure women and
spotless children if venereal diseases
were restricted to those who sought
illicit sexual gratification it might be
better to let the guilty suffer and die
there are also many innocent victims
because as you get it from towels and
drinking what not so they are saying so
they're validating the towel the dairy
the Committee on the Prevention of
venereal diseases is dumber than anyone
else it says that everyone that everyone
who has it should die because because
they are sinners kids right but also
that pure women and spotless children
bottlers oh they're clean as hell
they're spotless cleaned about this
board it meant almost everyone in
America believed that immigrants
arriving in the country worse if lytic
boy just it is just the same [ __ ]
different day all the [ __ ] time I
mean the fact that everyone here came
from somewhere else and it's just the
1800s it's not that far off from when
everyone [ __ ] arrived yeah and now
everyone who comes on a boat as I
guarantee you there's like Irish people
have been there for like a year like
gotta keep these [ __ ] immigrants a
they're [ __ ] itchy genitals Oh auntie
[ __ ] wax our ears so that belief
persisted even though all immigrants
were given a medical exam out of 11,000
immigrants arriving at Ella
Ellis Island in July
18:21 only 43 had a venereal disease
she's an Italian doctor who came in 1920
said he had to fight wild accusations
that syphilis was common among arriving
Italians
yeah well what are you talking about
it's just a spicy meatball hey I'm sorry
it's spicy meatballs two of them and
I've got about them and of course
Americans had to combine their
syphilitic fears with racism of course
black black people give it to you by
thinking they look at you weird and you
have syphilis exactly black people in
the early nineteen hundred's were called
quote a notorious syphilis soaked race
and mind you they probably had like the
lowest numbers of syphilis they actually
had high numbers you know in my opinion
that number is probably pretty high for
them too and they had an ever-increasing
low standards of sexual morality
according to from a medical journal
quote the Negro springs from a southern
race and as such his sexual appetite is
strong virginity is rare and a Negro
girl over 18 this is the reason for the
high rate of syphilitic s-- until some
curb is placed on the promiscuous sexual
communication in the class of these
people or until proper therapeutic
measures are forced upon them syphilis
will want to rife among them and
threaten those with whom they come in
contact it really that's a medical jury
is amazing how you'll never be
comfortable with the way that they would
talk about it's it's [ __ ] remarkable
yeah really I mean it sounds like when
you watch a nature documentary and the
duck the cheetah travels in packs
because it's like yeah the Negro is
known for its outlandish behavior yeah
don't look the negro in the eye maybe
the black people have a higher rate of
syphilis because they don't have good
medical care well I would also think
that if like hearing what you're talking
about
like syphilis came from white people so
Indians or
it's yeah but then it was only after
that it was the what it was white people
so it cut it's like they was probably
introduced in the slave culture via
[ __ ] white bigots right all right who
were hot for [ __ ] who liked who liked
the Noddy [ __ ] the naughty [ __ ] yeah you
know one you weren't supposed to do and
don't say it out loud because Quentin
Tarantino making a new movie it's true
in 1910 the Rockefeller Institute for
medical research started studying
syphilis to find better treatments one
researcher was using an inactive
solution of syphilis but he was using it
on children without the parents consent
who is this hero what he would inject
them with the inactive form of syphilis
to use them as they control but people
are obviously furious when they found
out about it but the DA's office decided
not to prosecute a guy was giving kids
syphilis inactive regardless regardless
he's given him off-the-clock syphilis
and if that's the actual term and
parents rightfully so are livid I would
be my would be upset if they gave my
child an active civil I think you would
too I think you'd still be thinking
about the triple play but then right
after you'd be like yeah it's not cool
he's got syphilis and the DEA is like
well it's just not easy it's gonna be
not gonna be easy what are you gonna do
what are you do I'm gonna do they got it
now you come on what you gonna do in
1916 they was discovered a different
researcher was puncturing the brains of
patients to see if there was any active
syphilis bacteria in their brains also
not getting consent okay let's just keep
going
but there was a medical breakthrough in
1922 getting a malaria inoculation when
suffering from late-stage syphilis would
suppress the disease in 50% of people so
that's when you already [ __ ] though
right but but what would it is so then
so it makes you not die him go crazy
like it halts the but you're still I
mean you've got some issues yeah
nobody's gonna want to help you spread
it that's correct
late-stage syphilis was a bit of a
nightmare it would affect the spinal
cord which affected the legs bladder and
anus blindness and deafness were common
and then there was paresis a progressive
mental degeneration the victim would
slowly head toward gibbering idiocy
which would finally end in death on the
journey they'd have delusions and often
act violently and due to this they had
to be put in asylums that's how I want
to go why not just gibberish talking
psychopath alone in a room yeah from
[ __ ] from [ __ ] during World War
one the Secretary of War
Newton Baker said a radius of ten miles
around a base where prostitution and
selling alcohol to soldiers was illegal
okay somehow I still think they can get
access to syphilis and official army
bulletins it read quote sexual
intercourse is not necessary for good
health and complete abstinence is
possible Wow okay I mean there's a it's
almost seems like there was there's more
abstinence today than there was back
that I mean come on
there's no one [ __ ] practiced
abstinence ever there's people now who
do really there are yeah yeah I mean so
they're not the people we should the
rates of anal amongst those girls who
saw the dude
anal doesn't count God doesn't pay
attention to the backdoor
he's just the front door man fair enough
I clearly don't have an argument yeah so
what was known as the American plan was
created it would provide wholesome
activities for soldiers and teach them
about VD and remind troops that
prostitution was illegal you boys don't
need [ __ ] let's play dodgeball and
don't and also those ladies are illegal
they're Lego giving them money is it
legal now this is a frisbee once you
throw this you're not gonna want to have
sex again the first time after you
frisbee I didn't [ __ ] my wife for a year
I'll do the talking turtle and when I
did I put it in her honor Colonel
Colonel Costa the giant hurdle you were
warned was no longer something her that
I was interested in colonel this frees
Morano turned me into what's known as an
ass man Colonel please silence colonel
anyway I think you'll have a lot of fun
throw the disc around today boys Colonel
alert I had never come so hard on some
of the wholesome activities included
swimming pools church sponsored picnics
concerts parades chaperoned dances and
beach parties you know I think in a way
a parade would make you never want to
[ __ ] again it would be great if you
could get syphilis from swimming though
and then they were like god damn it we
can't even swim how great would that be
no swimming so the red-light districts
of San Francisco were closed which just
meant hundreds of sex workers moved to
dance halls in the city streets okay
in San Diego they solicited solicited
soldiers in cafes hotel dining rooms
bars and on the streets okay so they
just made it worse yeah they just set
like an army of [ __ ] out the War
Department then concluded closing red
light districts just move sex workers to
other areas so they China their options
first they tried to get the women jobs
in war work you can help build tanks
that's right ahead of [ __ ] the War
Department believed that the women could
quote adopt middle class behavior and
proper standards of behavior but soon
they were detaining women suspected of
prostitution or being loose I was doing
it for free they go they reason that
they were protecting soldiers from
syphilis and gonorrhea okay in 1918
President Wilson appropriated 250,000
dollars to create detention homes for
delinquent women okay 18,000 women of
whom 15,000 520 had VD were committed to
institutions between 1918 and 1920 Wow
staggering number
yeah each woman was held for an average
of 10 weeks many were committed without
trial or due process well encouraged by
the War Department local and state
governments passed laws requiring
medical examination of citizens
reasonably suspected of being infected
with syphilis so a almost a genital
Gestapo yeah that's about right
Jesus how you doing ma'am Thanks okay
mind if I take a look under that dress
that gives us probable cause look at her
badge
look at her badge in Virginia health
officials hey sir how's your dick it's
good can I see it no can I put it in my
hand no rip his pants off check out his
D and Virginia health officials were
given the green light to examine
vagrants prostitutes and quote persons
not of good Fame 30 turns so sorry
anyone not famous yes this sounds like
what they tried in Arizona a couple
years ago with Mexicans it's pretty
similar 32 states in the u.s. passed
laws for mandatory examination and
detention of prostitutes government
officials says they said things like 90%
of VD cases or the fault of women that
really is amazing
especially when you're pulling numbers
out of your ass and out of thin air to
go with 90% [ __ ] it's impossible it
would be eradicated almost if it was
just 90% of women also come on it's men
it's totally well you can't say it's not
both I mean let's be honest for sure men
are much worse and men are yes men men
would be carriers right I mean it's not
like yeah yeah Jesus
90% he the government official said that
men were more cautious and more more
likely to seek treatment and that
prostitutes committed moral and social
murder we've always said that when it
comes to sex men are the ones who are
way more responsible
and they don't think with their dicks
it's just a bunch of women thinking with
their vaginas thank you there again
thank you you know we're getting to the
heart of it thank you
cops and judges just assumed women
exhibiting immoral behavior were
diseased government pamphlets warned men
to stay away from women quote willing to
give you a good time well let's of
course that's the craziest pamphlet
that's ever existed well it's called
it's basically like hey don't have fun
here you go ones that have fun whoever
wants to [ __ ] but still stay away from
women that look like they're a good time
woman we're gonna put it out you don't
want them go with the loser ladies a
poster claimed 70% of all loose women
had syphilis or gonorrhea 70% of all
like they're a category there is no
reliable statistic to make that claim no
at the facilities treatment was done by
force they were given as many as 19
shots and Mercury rubbings Oh Mercury
rubbings like GL the facilities were
surrounded by barbed wire fences only
female visitors and fathers were allowed
if there was not separate housing for
black women the black women would be put
in jail
Jesus Christ for having syphilis for
having syphilis films were produced of
soldiers and civilians working in for
soldiers and civilians working in
factories the movie fit to fight oh boy
has a great plot about five soldiers and
several prostitutes the star of the film
Billy Hale refused to have anything to
do with the prostitutes one of the other
guys kisses a prostitute and then runs
back to the base where he grows a
cancerous athletic lesion on his lip so
it's almost like reefer madness but of
Sifl for syphilis right amazing
the other three dudes get busy one goes
back to camp and quickly gets treatment
for VD the other two soldiers go back to
the brothel and continue to have fun and
both get VD at the same time they all
make fun of Billy for not banging
prostitutes and then Billy beats them up
that part is strange it's a good
thinking about the after it like it all
sounds like an after-school special
until your hero beats up the other guys
but he because they were making fun of
him so they had
show that you can stand up and not deal
with the period [ __ ] out of anyone who
tries to [ __ ] near you that's right I
would love to hear some of the dialogue
from that back in the day it must be
some sure we can still find oh must be
great I feel like I've seen it over at
my friend Josh's because we watch a lot
of this yeah we watch a lot of those old
timey moral sort of I thought you were
watching a lot of like VD so what we do
a video you and your buddy Josh just get
together the V beat I'm still this this
plan didn't work that great during World
War one VD was the second most common
reason for disability in absence of duty
it led to 7 million lost person days and
the discharge of more than 10,000
soldiers it almost like the tactic
almost sounds like the war on drugs a
little bit because it's like when you
criminalize something right that people
are automatically going to do you just
get overwhelmed with the numbers right
and you don't actually solve anything
you just create another symptom right
yep after the war the Federal Public
Health Service took over fighting VD but
now the religions got busy the religions
religion oh [ __ ]
funding holds a snake and your genitals
have come back that's exactly right
we're about to get to that oh good
funding was cut for million from 4
million in 1920 to under $60,000 in 1926
Wow
the film fit to fight was declared
obscene by the New York State Board of
censor the pennsylvania board of censors
banned any film that used the term
venereal disease so the angle now is 2d
educate to just stop talking about it
that's right because syphilis only comes
around your genitals only burn when
syphilis as ears are burning
that's right if you can hear the word
syphilis you can get it if you sell this
is like beetlejuice if you say it three
times it appears on your [ __ ] thank you
the Catholic Church objected to fit to
fight because men and it cleansed their
genitals after sex to prevent syphilis
but the whole point was it didn't work
but they did do that in the film this so
the church takes issue with basically
just like a scene that could have been
cut
yeah okay good smart the rate of
syphilis in the 1930s was between five
and ten percent
[ __ ] how [ __ ] crazy is that oh you
aren't you're in a restaurant someone in
there has syphilis yeah baby - yeah in
November in 1934 the incoming Director
of Public Health Service was supposed to
give a speech on CBS radio about public
health needs but CBS objected to him
saying syphilis he wouldn't change the
speech and left without giving it the
Health Commission of New York objected
to the censorship on radio the president
of NBC wrote quote radio broadcasts had
to be careful about what they allow on
the air because they receive a good deal
of criticism from parents who believe
that their children should not hear
information on certain topics no matter
how important they seem well that's the
craziest thing to say they shouldn't
hear about it no matter how important it
is that's basically what he's saying
political correctness over society's
well-being yes crazy medical cures
flourished one man said he had a machine
that could diagnose syphilis from a
person's autograph why can't we talk to
him
damn it that's the greatest man ever no
no go ahead and put your autograph right
down there you're good here yeah looks
fine looks okay I got bad news about
your friend though look at your
signature very stiffly that giant loop
there that loop says that your that
loops if you have a big ego and your
dick will fall off you have AIDS okay
you don't know what it is yet you're
gonna it's the AIDS a graph an Eric
clinic offered treatment a patient would
sit naked on a toilet seat type thing I
already love this one he's back against
a metal plate and his scrotum suspended
in a pool of water
oh they're waterboarding nuts the metal
plate would then be shocked with
electricity what wait wait they would
put him on an electric chair toilet put
his balls in water
and then zap him yeah what is the balls
in water do let's cure syphilis but the
whole body's getting alike what is it's
just better if it's in the water
oh my god that is just a spit ball
session gone wrong imagine the first guy
he's like sorry let's go down south I
mean it sounds to put your balls in the
water sounds reasonable right okay all
right patient 1 are you ready
oh no that man oh my God my balls
that's right yeah am i cured um yep
there's blood coming out of my penis uh
hold on no talking for a minute [ __ ]
it's one reason that these crazy cures
did well was that early symptoms of
syphilis vanish so it looked like the
Cure was working but that's just the
dormancy you were speaking well but in
truth those people were spreading the
disease right cuz they thought they were
like I can [ __ ] again I'm good again
because they sat in a toilet where their
balls were that's when swimming in 1938
FDR signed a bill giving 15 million for
the National venereal disease control
Act okay this would set up more
diagnosis and treatment centers and to
get the word out there was a play
written called a Spiro Chet Spiro Chet
is the bacterial family syphilis is part
of there were 32 performances of the
play in Chicago during an emission you
could get free blood tests for syphilis
in the lobby people went to this yep a
play was written about syphilis
yep called Spiro shet mm-hmm and you
could get a blood test yeah you get the
same thing at Hamilton that's true
actually yeah you can you can get tested
for rap in 1932 the Tuskegee Institute
and the Public Health Service began a
study in Macon County Alabama the golda
study was to learn the effects of
untreated syphilis
meagan county's population was 27,000
22,000 of which were African Americans
between 1932 and 9th
72 399 low-income african-american men
were given syphilis no and told they
were being given free medical care while
being given no treatment for the disease
oh my god
most of the men had not been educated
beyond the seventh grade they were told
they had a condition of bad blood they
were never told they were part of a
study they were never told they had
syphilis they were told nothing of the
reality of the study that's so crazy
that's like that's such that's like
concentration camps Joe knows we're
[ __ ] monsters it's monstrous
that's mom raised free health care I
mean that is the same as like telling
well I won't get into them prior to the
u.s. entering World War two the military
held conferences on how to deal with
gonorrhea and syphilis during the war I
would love to have any one of those come
oh god no I'm kidding I'm kidding come
on you guys I'd [ __ ] you right now I
actually have a theory
go ahead I think if you suspend a
gentleman with ropes at vary his
testicles in earthy soil that if you
leave him there for a week after fully
watering his underground halls I believe
that that might get rid of what we're
all worried about okay can we send him
to the front lines thank you so they
grappled with whether it feels like myth
of the no they grappled with whether or
not they should let men with syphilis
fight at first no infected men were
allowed to fight the enemy in World War
two let me [ __ ] the enemy right yeah
that's the move thank you
you should drop syphilitic men into
japan you as the war dragged on though
the restrictions gave way and two
hundred thousand men with VD fought
against the Germans and Japanese Wow
films such as films known as Suzy crotch
rot films were shown to soldiers I am
sorry
films known as Suzy crotch rot films
were shown to shortages Suzy
roxrite yeah so you spent all this time
like being like don't say syphilis and
now we're at the point where not only do
say syphilis but name a character crotch
rot I think that was just the nickname
the soldiers gave him pamphlets were
given out training included info about
VD quote you can't beat the axis with VD
was a slogan you can't beat the access
oh right sorry I was thinking access to
spelled differently
soldiers were chemists thinking like
that was saying like you get better
access with VD soldiers were given
condoms with their equipment but
religious groups protested saying it
would just cause [ __ ] okay the Army
Surgeon General disagreed and the
condoms continued good once again
another war brought a crackdown on sex
workers social protection division and
the Secretary of War led the effort the
social protection division was headed by
Eliot Ness Wow
whose nemesis Al Capone was now
suffering from late-stage syphilis nez
Ness closed all the red-light districts
and brothels in 662 cities and towns
rapid treatment centers and quarantine
hospitals were created 47 of them were
opened by 1947 from Colliers magazine
when army doctors discover a soldier has
syphilis he is questioned at length and
lists of his contacts are made the girls
are rounded up for a check and if found
have syphilis they are taken to the
hospital immediately
State Police meet in coming buses uh
Ness courted girls who get off our
questioned if they are coming to meet
their husbands the troopers assist them
but if they give unsatisfactory answers
they are plenty informed that they must
undergo examination with suspect women
were arrested and examined they could be
picked up for vagrancy loitering or just
on suspicion well so that's anything
right a married woman a married woman
grabbed for vagrancy and pressured and
and was pressured to voluntary commit
herself this was because she had eaten
lunch alone after leaving her job as a
waitresses were already looked upon as
suspicious what the woman tested
negative and was released another woman
is arrested for being drunk she did not
list an occupation on her intake form he
was probably drunk she did not listen to
occupation on their intake form so the
social worker just filled in prostitute
a [ __ ] she's a [ __ ] she doesn't have a
job [ __ ] the centers and hospitals were
known as prostitution prison camps good
they had locked gates barbed wire fences
and no visitors were allowed this is
1947 we're locking up waitresses
I mean honestly and you thought we did
that at TGI Fridays we should do it at E
Jeffrey we already do boom getting it
the US Army began using a newly
discovered penicillin to treat gonorrhea
in 1943 dr. John Mahoney then decided to
take some and test it on syphilis it
worked
the impact was huge in June of 1944 the
army adopted penicillin for syphilis
treatment syphilis infection steadily
declined so obviously new infected
people were needed to study why don't
from 1946 to 1948 US public health
doctors infected almost 700 Guatemalans
with VD they were prison inmates mental
patients and soldiers okay why would you
just go what why would you just land on
a like a a certain kind of people why
did it have to be 700 Guatemalans I
think that they they probably made some
sort of deal with a Guatemalan
government to just and then they're like
let's do higham yeah okay
so then they they would they would give
me syphilis it was done the name of
science to test how effective penicillin
was it was paid for with American tax
dollars the National
of health paid for syphilis infected sex
workers to have sex with the prisoners
but you can in glad him all you
prisoners could have sex with they would
sorry say that again so they would have
syphilitic infected prostitutes come in
go into the prisons and [ __ ] the
prisoners to give them syphilis yeah
but in some cases the prostitutes did
not infect the men so the bacteria was
poured into scrapes made on their
penises faces or arms ah what you have
faces are arms I know right like I'm
you're not asking for much I know don't
scrape it into his how about a little
respect little did the arm arm it was
even injected via spinal taps [ __ ] when
anyone came down with syphilis they were
given penicillin unlike the Tuskegee
victims the Tuskegee victims were never
given standard treatments by government
doctors they did not offer penicillin
when it became the standard method of
curing the disease why the study was
finally ended in 1970 after it was
leaked to the public by then perhaps as
many as a hundred men had died from
syphilis the men that were still alive
were then given treatment in December of
1974 the US government agreed to pay ten
million in an out-of-court settlement or
$37,000 per participant
oh well that oh that's fine that's
enough for the torture of almost dying
from syphilis where syphilis came from
has been up for debate for a long time
until the 20th century he was believed
syphilis was brought from America to the
old world by Christopher Columbus but
then in the 1980s studies came up with
possible evidence supporting the
hypothesis that syphilis was an
old-world disease which evolved they
said that 50 skeletons found there
proved this to be true but upon peer
review when the skeletons were looked at
by experts
there was zero conclusive evidence that
the skeletons had syphilis so current
prevailing theory
theory is that Columbus brought syphilis
to the old world from America primary
and secondary syphilis rates are today
increasing good syphilis has been
quietly evolving resistance to some
antibiotics that we used to treat it
although penicillin is still effective
and as the main way we treat it here in
the United States and a silicon US
United States of America okay so can we
say this if okay so Christopher Columbus
found a land where people already lived
right and claimed he discovered it right
so then he picked up an STD that people
already had but he brought it back as
well so Columbus also discovered
syphilis as much as he discovered
America he discovered syphilis yeah
that's so we need to figure out a way to
rhyme that Columbus discovered syphilis
yeah he did I mean the 1492 Columbus
sailed the ocean blue and also that year
it burned when he pissed because he
brought back lots of syphilis there we
go boom girl made up a song [ __ ]
everybody feels weird I do not I'm not a
proponent of syphilis just so that I'm
on record
oh I'm anti I'm a big fan I'm anti big
fan sorry Guatemala love it all right
well we sent cards X X X X